okay we're talking about on your only
fans just pictures or do you have to
does stevie help you edit [ __ ] videos
and chat no uh
i tend to just take all the photos
myself like
what i found through research is a lot
of instagram girls like to do like
almost like photo shoot style where
everything's
very produced and then there's a niche
for people who like to see you do like
day-to-day [ __ ] that looks more like
instagram that's what i growl
yeah as if like you sent the picture to
them yes yeah
that's the difference have you been
selling uh
undies in your socks still uh socks i
have i
sold one pair of underwear and then
afterwards i was like hmm not gonna do
this anymore did they pay a premium
though
they paid a pretty penny for it like a
hundo
yeah you got it did when were they worn
underwear
yeah it was like once i went to the gym
like two days ago
waiting on it yeah people dig that man
people dig that yeah
so girl on your mom's house showed this
video this guy he's like whispering he's
like my wife's asleep
he's actually got these underwear
and he goes she goes you know this guy's
so weird he's like yeah she says she's
24.
just got done working out because this
is where her pooper would be used
oh that's raunchy oh yeah yeah he goes
i'm hard
i'm hard as he's like trying to whisper
because his wife sleeps
i'm so hard right now he's all like it's
a stateful commercial oh my gosh
why would you record yourself too i
don't know next year bring it up chin
it's it's your mom's house on their
youtube underwear yeah they're youtube
that's one of the best podcasts out
there
he's like oh i'm so hard right now yeah
put your leave your underwear on the
phone no not that one
go down that's right maybe all right
yeah that's there and then searching
there
um i know it's the beginning of their
episode go down
recent one um let me go to videos i
would probably yeah probably three weeks
ago
yeah they have two main videos yeah um
what's your
four weeks three weeks um
see if it's the three weeks ago this one
587 yeah
he's like ooh that's pungent that's
exactly what daddy's about the way that
cigar broke his arm
basketballs bunch i didn't know he was a
hooper
i hear everybody you know yeah [ __ ]
on
america's politics i'm like have you
read familiar germans
apparently we haven't heard about them
nope go go you guys are
clowns i think those three weeks ago go
to the one that says
uh go down this one no go down that's
two weeks ago
it's not two weeks ago go to that one
month ago see if that's it this one
go to ymhstudios.com super natural
being i'm not gonna know what are you
go back gin all i am we'll find it
um two weeks ago i don't think it was
two weeks ago
what what did we just get which one did
we just go to
wasn't this one uh go to the two months
ago see if that's it
see the one that says 581
hi mommies and chomos and my queen's
above 18.
this episode was recorded a few weeks
ago
uh before we had an incident where my
husband
nope because this was playing basketball
against it has to be uh
earlier than this so that was that was
before he broke his
one two weeks ago then maybe go
two that's three go though they go yeah
i go that one
yeah 586. one
one one no this one what is it what what
what is it yeah yeah no
we just do our proper show openings
antibodies are just great
amy thank you covered i've got the
antibodies buddy
all right let's start the show excited i
i mean let's do it let's get ready
that looks like the where the bunk hole
was right cause they kind of look like
kind of look like [ __ ] stains oh yeah
there's the [ __ ] right there
so let's give it a whiff it gets his
nose ready
oh that is pungent punches
you can actually smell some [ __ ] oh my
goodness this is hot
this is giving me a boner right now
erection achieved
actually [ __ ] achieved dude what's up
dog
how crazy that's kind of weird those are
who are buying your underwear that's
who's money
you know i try not to think too much
about what they do with it i just sell
it and now
i have a very clear doing it
teach image own yeah keep doing it yeah
[ __ ] funny though
not really funny it's just kind of gross
would you sell your underwear
no again i'm not going to the post
office in ups the ship underwear it's
too much
i can't send my brother a pair of shoes
because i'm not going
taking time i'm too lazy for me that's
how i felt too i felt like i was
shipping off like a little secret
they would ask you to like oh what's it
have like clothes
oh there's some clothes what's the value
of this 50 bucks
get an assistant cat who does it for you
just have my sister work for me yeah
hire your sister to make the shipments
yeah yeah just have her do it
keep it in the thing though like uh i
don't know i had
a weird feeling after i sent it out i
was like well this is the only one i'm
probably gonna do
you only did one yeah i only did one if
it's popping like if there's a demand i
would i mean
yeah i'd keep what are we doing here
yeah [ __ ] it
how many requests a day do you get from
like panties uh panties i'll get maybe
two or three a day
you get socks more though on socks at
the beginning i
got and then they kind of fizzled out
now a lot of people want dick ratings
decorate like how big is my yeah like
they'll send a picture of their dick
and watch the picture for that that's
the thing i don't open any photos or
videos because
they have the same feature as instagram
where it's blurred out so you have to
click on it in order to see
yeah and i tell people i don't open up
photos or videos unless you
i'm doing a dick rating and i try to
deter people from
showing me their dick or seeing it so
i'm like oh it's
i don't know like fifty dollars they're
like okay and some people are willing to
pay fifty dollars
yeah so like i'll do it for fifty
dollars but anything other than that so
what do you
say i tell them how i feel about their
dinner
and what are you really so what is it
like this is fantastic like like
so the dick comes out on thursday so
like
i will tell them what i think about size
and like the actual photo itself like if
you're like
sending this to someone i'm like okay
maybe change the angle here like i don't
like this position but if you do this
maybe like trim
before you send a photo are you getting
big dicks
uh i've gotten i'd say like two or three
big dicks and everything else is pretty
average
yeah three arrows makes sense yeah
yeah that's a cool because if you got a
big ding-a-ling you don't need a dick
that's the thing you don't need a
decorating it's more so you want me to
see your dick that's right that's yeah
it's not about
like actually raiding the deal yeah
because i want you to know what i'm
working average just trying to know
what's up like hey
like i just want to make sure
everything's good yeah yeah what a crazy
business you've created
yeah yeah good for you good for you i'm
happy
i'm traumatizing i'm going to make these
vlogs
it's a little bit more a little more
time consuming
chin filming everything tell us what you
think of that korean barbecue
hey bro get out of my face cat helps me
though cause
if i put her in a thumbnail you get way
more clicks chin likes to use me as
clickbait i do
i decided to do only fans if anyone's
gonna monetize off of me it's gonna be
me correct
there you go there we go i made 500 [ __ ]
you made what i mean five dollars this
month
for what i'm just kidding from your vlog
oh they don't make much money if you
don't get your ass the only fans stop
bullshitting
i know that dangling playing
yeah it's a little different 40 year old
dude but you got the editing skills and
stuff you know
i feel like i'm going to help you let me
be able to help you out i know
everyone's saying
too i just don't know what to do
tick-tock was looking for like young
influencers
like yeah bro if you don't post your r
b singing ass on ted talk bruh get a lot
of you gotta seriously think about it
then
how about that when i get off stage at
the lab factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this is from
a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son